Good morning!
*Acoustic jam*
Good news everybody, we're getting free lunch today
YES!
awwwww, food baby
I could totally have a cat, or six
oh, Steven..
Hey Mom, are you excited to have me home for Thanksgiving?
Hey listen, can you book the plane ticket?
Yea but Dad how do you even know when you have to pay taxes?
What do you mean everybody pays them?
No, yea, buit why would I pay any more than the minimum?
*GASP!*
We have Pop Tarts, now!
Can you believe Scotland didn't get its independence?
I know, right? It's like:
They may take our lives but they will never take our freedom!!!!!
It's from Braveheart, guys..
This is a responsibility that our company takes seriously. It should be everybody's personal duty.
*Bubbly laughing*
Do you have something to add, Gaby?
You said "Duty", so...
Yes, serious duties for all of us.
Everyone in here
This is a personal duty
Serious duty
personal duty
duty, duty,duty
yes, a very serious duty
We each have a serious duty?
yes, inside of us